nagyon gyakran feltődik az a kérdés hogy
meg tudjuk-e mondani azt valamiről és
hosszútvon meg fogjuk tudni
mondani-e hogy hogy azt ember vagy gép
készítette hogy az deep fake vagy nem és
jelen pillanatban úgy néz ki hogy ezt
csak akkor tudjuk megmondani hogyha
ismerjük azt a modellt ami generálja
mert azzal be lehet tanítani egy olyan
másik modellt ami megmondja hogy ezt
most a a tengerá generálta vagy ezt most
a mid journey generálta vagy ezt most a
d generálta mert mert hogy ezek ismert
[Zene]
modellek nemrég fejeztem be a
beszélgetést szabó péterrel egy
hihetetlenül intenzív és izgalmas
beszélgetés volt amelyben egy kicsit
áttekintettük a mesterséges
intelligenciának az elmúlt 40 évét hogy
milyen nagyobb dolgok történtek és mitől
lett a chat gpti az elmúlt időszakban
ekkora médiaszenzáció nagyon izgalmas
témákat érintettünk egyrészt hogy a hét
köznapi ember hogyan is tudja ezeket
használni mi történik akkor hogyha
lemarad erről és milyen előnyei vannak
milyen veszélyei vannak beszéltünk egy
kicsit a jövőről is arról hogy mi fog
körülbelül történni a következő években
mire számíthatunk úgyhogy tartsatok
velünk és iratkozzatok fel a csatornákra
üdvözöllek péter a navigátor podcastbe
köszönöm hogy elvállaltad a beszélgetést
én legalábbis nagyon vártam ezt a
beszélgetést és csapjunk akkor bele
köszönöm szépen a meghívást én is vártam
talán a leg legjobb kezdés az hogyha egy
kicsit a hallgatókat is képbe helyezzük
hogy mikkel foglalkoztál eddig és miért
szerettem volna veled leülni kicsit
mesélnél arról a szakmai háttérről
ahonnan jössz és hogy hogy milyen
nagyobb cégekbe vettél részt milyen
nagyobb teljesítményeket szeretsz
úgymond magadénak tudni és és amire
büszke is vagy az elmúlt évek során a
karrieremben szerintem a a az egyik
legfontosabb mérföldkő az
az az volt amikor kikerültem londonba az
már több mint 10 évvel ezelőtt volt egy
egy startupnak az igazgatói székébe
csöppentem egy egy what users do nevű
startupnak amit egy
eg egy brit úriember bizonyos lid adle
alapított és neki sajnos volt egy
nagyon durva kvázi életveszélyes
balesete a amit szerencsé túlélt viszont
13 hónapra
beteg szabadságra került ameddig
felépült és kellett valaki aki
helyettesíti
őt szakmailag és és így kerültem kvázi
egyik napról a másikra londonba én én
úgy gondolom hogy
a szerencsétlenségben volt egy olyan
óriási szerencse hogy itt
rengeteget tanultam arról hogy hogy
működnek a startupok
hogy működik a a gazdaság hogy lehet
nagy cégekkel
tárgyalni bármi ilyesmi meg meg meg
szakmailag is tudtam fejlődni akkor még
felhasználó élménykutatással
foglalkoztam ugye a what users do egy
egy user experience research platform
volt aminek aztán volt egy sikeres
exitje aminek hát a az
előkészítésében én is részt vettem és
úgy gondolom hogy hogy valamennyire a
tevékenységem meghatározta legalábbis
azt az egy évét vagy 13 hónapját ameddig
lt helyettesítettem és ezt igazából l
tudnám
megmondani utána mikor szerencsére lee
felépült akkor pedig átkerültem a világ
legnagyobb szerencsejátékos
részvénytársaságához ami nem nem csak
szerencsejátékos hanem mindenféle
játékos de vannak egyéb brandek is ez a
flutter
incorporated de mondjuk a a profit
jelentős része a szkból származik ezért
mondják úgy hogy ez egy ilyen gambling
company ugye talán a poker stars a
legismertebb brand tőlük és és itt egy
egy business unitot vezettem a ami
a hát egy kicsit
ilyen há
ugye abba abb az időben úgy hozták létre
a a a business unitot hogy addig a
különböző brandeknél volt a user
experience ui és frontend funkció és ezt
egy
ilyen corporate szintű
központi funkcióba vonták össze és akkor
gyakorlatilag én megörököltem a uxui
frontend s-eket a különböző
brandekből és így így jött létre ez volt
a a kezdete ennek a az egységnek és
én úgy gondolom hogy nagyon sikeresek
voltunk
rengeteg játékos projektet el tudtunk
indítani és nem csak viszont a a másik
dolog és a a későbbi karrierem során
szerintem ez ez a két dolog meghatároz
hogy egyrészt közben össze tudtam
foglalni a a uxui kutatásaimat és és
akkor ezt könyv formájában pack
publishing kiadta
2017-ben másrészt pedig
lehetőséget biztosított arra hogy hogy
elkezdjek a gépi tanulásban jobban
elmélyülni na most azért hozzá tartozik
hogy ez körülbelül olyan 10 évvel
ezelőtt volt amikor úgy úgy elkezdtem
belemélyedni hogy nagyon más volt a gépi
tanulás nem a nem a matematikája volt
más ugye azt a azt jóval azelőtt ugye
láthattuk az idén hogy
82-es illetve 85 ötös kutatásokért a a
méneorális állok terén nobelíjat adtak
fizikából úgyhogy nem nem az történt
hogy a matematika megváltozott hanem
elsősorban a a hardware és a a különböző
fejlesztői környezetek library ugye
megjelent a pytorch meg hardware szinten
megjelent az a100-as ami áttörést hozott
úgyhogy ebből a szempontból a még gyerek
cipőben járt a a gépi tanulás a mához
képest viszont mivel volt volt pénz
voltak erőforrások így így lehetett
nagyon érdekes elsősorban prediktí
modelleket tehát ilyen jövőbeli
események előrejelzését
szolgáló modelleket fejlesztgetni
viszont a én úgy gondolom hogy a aztán
akkor sikerült igazán elmélyülni és és
erre fog fókuszálni mikor haza tudtam
jönni erdélybe
ugye az az mindenként én úgy terveztem
hogy hogy nem nem szeretném londonba
leérni az életemet és hát úgy is úgy is
mentem ki angliában nagyon sokat
vaciláltam azelőtt hogy hogy menjek-e
külföldre dolgozni sok helyre hívtak
google-nél voltam- hétlépéses
interjúsorozaton aztán a végén nem
fogadtam el az állást ebből 11-ben
aziszem még újságcikk is született
de hogy én nagyon nem akartam külföldön
élni
és pont azért is mentem ki mert hogy
ugye ez a a what users do történet ez
egy ez egy ilyen meghatározott idejű
valami volt
és és így így akkor az ember jobban
belemegy hogyha tudod hogy na akkor
ennek egy év múlva vége van na de utána
aztán átment a a flatterhez amit amúgy
nagyon szerettem nagyon jó emberekkel
dolgoztam innen csak csak nem szerettem
külföldön élni és akkor kerestem hogy
hogy tudok hazajönni na és mikor
hazajöttem akkor akkor nagyon jó volt
mert tudtam egész érdekes projekteken is
dolgozni
és és ugye akkor tudtam arra fókuszálni
hogy hát gyakorlatilag azt azt csináljom
amit nagyon szeretek ebből a a a nagyon
szeretek témakörből én úgy gondolom hogy
most már a a a gépi tanulás és a
felhasználó élményközpontú gépi tanulás
van a a az elsők között ami a szakmai
téet na
most hát
a ami ami szerintem az egyik
legérdekesebb ez most már kezd így a
közelmúlt lenni úgyhogy bizonyos
projektekről annyira nem beszéltek
nyilvánosan viszont
ami amiről
igen az az mindenként egy egy egy ilyen
predikí gépi tanulási projekt
ami amiről aztán cikkeket is írtam meg
elég sok konferencián tartottam annak
idején előadást ez ez még a koronavírus
járvány előtt volt de én úgy gondolom
hogy ma is érdekes tehát egy olyan egy
olyan modellt fejlesztettünk ami
előrejelzi
áruházakban a a a gaktári
nyilvántartásnak a a az igényét tehát
gyakorlatilag megmondja azt hogy egy
adott webáruház adott raktárában melyik
termékből mennyit kell raktározni hogy
az elfogyjon a következő egy két- három
hónapb most ez így ez így nagyon
száraznak hangzik az is nyilván mert egy
csomó számban egy másik csomó számot
generálunk
viszont ezt ezt gyakorlatba ültettük
például volt egy ö egy oroszországi
úriember bizonyos kechinov
akinek volt
akkor két webáruház az egyik 20 millió a
másik 8 millió felhasználóval tehát ezek
így európai szemmel nézve nagyon nagy
webáruházak és akkor meg tudtuk azt
jósolni hogy hogy melyik felhasználó
milyen valószínűséggel fog megvenni egy
terméket egy úgynevezett collaboraatí
filtering módszerre amit nyilván lehet
ajánlani és is a felhasználónak de ami
ugye oroszországban az igazán nagy
probléma volt akkor az az hogy óriásiak
a távolságok de a a vásárlók elvárják
hogy azért hogyha megveszi az új
iphone-t akkor egy-két napon belül ki is
hozza a futárt és hogyha mondjuk az a
moskva oblastban van raktárba és a
mondjuk vladivostockban van a
felhasználónk akkor az nem ideális tehát
ezért akkor vladivostoki raktárba kell
tenni de ugyanakkor a másik oldalról a
az pedig óriási pénzveszteség hogyha
beteszünk abba a raktárba egy iphone-t
és akkor azt nem veszi meg senki egy-két
három en hónapon belül most nyilván a a
háború miatt ezt ezt nem tudom hogy a
aztán a
a mi a mi az utó élete a projektnek de a
a a ameddig tudtunk dolgozni velünk meg
ameddig ezt tudtuk követni addig ez egy
ez egy nagyon sikeres történet volt de
de de sok más
érdekes gépitanáási projekt is
volt viszont a a én én úgy gondolom hogy
a a a az egyik legfontosabb dolog hogy
hogy egy egy nagyon szép
fejlesztő csapat épült fel itt
majosvásárhelyen
a amikor kaptunk egy nagyobb befektetést
akkor akkor szépen tudtunk
nőni is ugye a az az étekről van szó
aminek itt a kosut utcában van a
székhelye a
egy egy adott
pillanatban egy ilyen hat hónap
leforgása alatt fel tudtunk venni 30
nagyon jó embert és akkor eljutottunk
42 főre ha nem tévedek és és én úgy
tudom hogy ezeknek az embereknek nagy
része mai napig is a az zészteknél
dolgozik és és hatékony kollégák na most
nyilván egy ilyen két és fél évvel
ezelőtt
a azt a döntést hoztam a a többi
tulajdonossal közösen hogy akkor eladom
a tulajdonrészemet a az étekből és és
akkor egy egy másik startupot indítottam
ez a ez a másik startup ez viszont egy
egy sokkal látványosabb irányba vitte el
a dolgokat itt ez a ez a tengré nevű
startup ami most már lehet hogy
ismertebb is és mindenként látványosabb
és és nem nem egy business to business
valami hanem egy egy ilyen business to
custumer egy egy
egy részről nyilván van ennek
is b2b vagyis hogy más cégeknek
szolgáltató része de de alapvetően van
egy olyan ingyen használható webes
platform ahol mindenki kipróbálhatja a
képgeneráló a mesterséges intelligenciát
naá most ez a ez a történet ez
hát legalábbis a nyilvános része az
mindenként csíszeredáb
kezdődött
körülbelül két év és egy pár hónappal
ezelőtt a a úgy emlékszem hogy 22
október közepén volt a digitális
székelyföld konferencia az it plus
plaszter szervez éébe és akkor simon
károly aki a az it plusnak a a az
elnöke megkért hogy akkor próbáljunk meg
egy egy valami látványos kiállítást
összehozni mesterséges intelligenciával
ideális esetben a a majlát térre ami
ugye
a a a mozi adta a a a terét a
konferenciának és ez így pont csikszered
a mozi előtti tér
és hát ugye adta magát hogy a csíkszed a
lévén a csíi székely múzeummal
együttműködve megkaptuk nagy imre és
nagy istván digitalizált hagyatékát és
akkor ezt ezt és más nemzetközi festőket
is akiről jó minőségben digitalizált
hagyaték elérhető volt ilyen ilyen
ismertebb rembrant és társaira gondolok
hogy a hogy akkor csináljunk egy egy
mesterséges intelligenciával generált
képkiállítást én úgy tudom hogy a a
régióban mindenként elsőként de
európában talán az első vagy a második
ilyen kiállítás volt akkor még ug emzem
én is erre a kiállításra láttam
személyesen is meg itt
székelyudvarhelyen is ki volt állítva
azt hiszem a tavaly ugye hogyha jól
emlékszem a mintha a s war is 22ben volt
csak később mint az 22 novemberében lett
volna nem nem sokkal később volt mint a
a annak is van egy érdekes története az
udvarhelynek
hogy azért gondolom hogy most
szinte biztos vagyok hogy közel volt a
digitális székelyföldhöz mert mert ott
kezdtük
beszélni
a ugye ugyancsak a a az pl
klaszterrel dzsival és imonkóal közösen
ezt így néztük hogy akkor mit lehetne
csinálni
és és akkor udvarhelyen is a a
művelődési ház
előtt gondoltuk hogy jó lenne egy ilyen
kiállítás de most nyilván udvarhelyi
kiállítás révén adta magát hogy akkor
ezt ezt vigyük el paszteles irányba és
ugye maselka a híres udvarhelyi
pasztelművész és akkor ahhoz már
betanítottuk maselkánnak a
stílusát ezzel kapcsolatban már nem nem
nem aratott osztatlan sikert legalábbis
ez a része ugyanis hát egy nyilván nem
nem neked mondom hanem a aki nem nem
ismeri annyira a a udvarhelyt hogy
maselka az időben hozzánk sokkal
közelebbi festőművész
mint nagy imre vagy nagy istván és éppen
ezért
hát hálistennek él a fia viszont a a
kiállítás után a a a fia jelezte hogy
hát ő azért annyira nem örül annak hogy
a az édesapja stílusában a az emberek
millió számra generálhatják a képeket a
a az interneten valószínűleg te ismered
személyesen is
a a a festővénésznek a fiát
és akkor mondtam hogy ez ezt ezt
abszolút megértem és így így kegyeleti
okokból akkor kvázi elfelejtettük a a a
nagy modellel ezt a stílust és és közben
akkor erre ki is dolgoztunk egy olyan
módszert amivel tud felejteni adott
esetben egy stílust el tud felejteni egy
egy gépitonalási modell ez nagyon nagyon
érdekes etikai kérdéseket vesz fel és
ezekre mindenképpen rá akarok térni
viszont még előtte azért ki kíváncsi
vagyok hogy hogy mesélted hogy az elmúlt
pár hónapban folyamatosan utaztál nagyon
kíváncsi vagyok hogy miért utaztál is és
hogy hogy hogy mesélj egy kicsit erről a
pár pár hónapos tapasztalatodról hát
igen mindenként köszönöm a megértésedet
mertogy ezt már a nyáron elkezdtük
beszélni ezt a podcastet de aztán
most most jött
össze hát
alapvetően amit amit tapasztaltam hogy a
a az előző évekhez képest az idén nagyon
megnőtt a konferenciákon az érdeklődés a
mesterséges intelligencia iránt hát ugye
múlt héten is egy egy bécsi konferencián
voltam gyakorlatilag a augusztus
közepétől szeptember október november
rengeteg esemény volt 15 különböző
helyen tartottam
előadást
ez ez ez amúgy nagyon sok is tehát
egy egy picit úgy is érzem hogy
túlvállaltam magam
viszont szeretem a a ezt a
tudománynépszerűsítő előadás formát és a
kelkasztal beseszélgetéseket és minden
ilyesmi és hát már úgy
2011-12-től elég sok konferencián
tartottam előadást
viszont más
évekbe ilyen egész év alatt volt 510
maximum előadásom most meg kvázi három
hónap alatt volt 15 én én úgy gondolom
hogy ez ez
nem nem az én érdemem hanem hanem az a
az a
hatalmas méia buz az a az a hatalmas pr
tevékenység amit elsősorban az amerikai
startupok és gondol ak it főleg a az
open aial de ugyanúgy antrophic google a
facebook és a többi folytat és emiatt a
a a gépi tanulás vívmányai amit mondjuk
íg nyilván ainak szokás aposztrofálni
egy ilyen gyűjtőfogalomal a az ai az az
folyamatosan benne van a közbeszédbe és
és ugye 22 november
30-án publikusan elérhető lett a az open
a nak a gpt 3.5 turbo modellje amiből
aztán ugye a a a cat gpt nevű felületen
lehetett ezzel beszélgetni és és így ez
mindenkihez eljutott és most már oda
jutottunk hogy nagyon
sok ember fejében össze is mosódott a a
mesterséges intelligencia az open ai-al
és a chat gpt-vel ami érthető is ugye ez
mindig megtörténik úgy ahogy a a
fénymásolót nagyon sokan seroxnak
nevezik hott a a serox csak egy cég aki
gyárt
fénymásolókat ugyanúgy én úgy gondolom
hogy a eljutottunk oda hogy a a a
nagynyelvi modelleket sőt az egész
mesterséges
intelligenciát most már kezdik az
emberek c gpt-nek nevezni gyere rakjunk
akkor rendet kezdjük ezzel egyszer azzal
hogy valójában a hallgatóságunk azok
hétköznapi emberek les ne elárusítók
tanárok orvosok hétköznapi emberek akik
nem szakemberek és és talán jó lenne
hogyha leválasztanánk ezeket a
fogalmakat és és akár számomra is
tisztáznánk hogy mi micsoda pontosan
egyrészt említetted hogy a neurális
hálók már egy 40 éves sőt annál talán
azt hiszem hogy a 60-as években már
foglalkoztak a neurális
hálókkal de de mindenesetre a 80-as
évekbeli mondjam úgy hogy vívmányokért
kaptak most nobel díjat
mi mi egy neurális háló és és hogyan
fogalmaznád meg a jelentőségét ennek a
neurális hálónak alapvetően a a neurális
hálót azt úgy kell elképzelni picit
analóg módon egy egy
biológiai neurális hálónak a a a az
úgynevezett
mélytanulásban ezek a neuronok ezek
nagyon egyszerű nagyon a
szimpla dolgot megvalósító hát
gyakorlatilag függvények
viszont azáltal hogy ebből rengeteg van
egymás után mint egy hálózat és ezek
egymásnak adják át az információt
ezáltal nagyon bonyolult kérdések
megoldására ez jó tud lenni és mindennek
a kulcsa a a a hiba azt mondjuk a gépi
tanulásban mi hiba függvénynek nevezzük
de gyakorlatilag azért tanul a gép mert
egy hibát akar csökkenteni de
valószínűleg az ember is azért tanul úgy
tanuljuk meg hogy ne nyújunk a tűzbe
hogy vagy szól valaki vagy rosszabb
esetben megégetjük magunkat és akkor
tudjuk hogy az az hiba lenne hogyha
megint belenyúlnánk a tűzbe na egy
kicsit hasonlóan működik egy egy mély
neurális háló is ugye
kezdetben teljesen
véletlenszerűen mű möik de azáltal
hogy hogy valamilyen eredményt ad azt az
eredményt mindig egy egy úgynevezett
tanuló adathalmazba tehát egy ilyen nagy
adatmennyiségen amiből úgymond tanul a
gép azon ezt mindig ellenőrizzük és
gyakorlatilag ez a hibafüggvény ez azt
mondja meg hogy mennyire van távol a az
igazságtól egy adott válasz és it az
igazságot ne ne ne a ne az emberi
szempontból
igazságnak nevezzük talán ez nem is jó
kifejezés hanem hogy hogy mennyire nagy
hibát vétett ez főleg a nyelvi
modelleknél nagyon nagyon fontos ez a
hogy mindjárt visszatérünk oda hogy mi a
mi az igazság vagy mi a hibafüggvény de
mondok egy egy sokkal egyszerűbben
megérthető példát tegyük fel hogy valaki
szeretne egy olyan neurális hálót ami
ami sokkal hamarabb volt és sokkal
népszerűb mint a a a a nyelvi modellek
vagy a képgeneráló modellek azok a
tőzsdei kereskedő robotok és szeretne
valaki egy olyan neurális hálót ami
előre jelzi azt hogy a részvény hogy fog
alakulni na most ebben az esetben nagyon
egyszerű megmondani a hibát mertogy ugye
történelmi adatokon tanítjuk tudjuk hogy
bizonyos dolgok hatására hogy mozogtak a
részvények és akkor mi azt várjuk hogy
ha elmondj mondjuk mit tudom én
hogy 300 nap alatt hogy változott egy
részvény akkor a 31 302 303 napot
megpróbálja megjósolni ez a ez a háló és
a az elején teljesen véletlenszerűnek
tűnő eredményeket fog adni és és az is
végülis viszont azáltal hogy tegyük fel
hogy most van egy mit tudom én nvidia
részfény most az a az a legnépszerűbb
meg a a marketc szempontjából az az
egyik legértékesebb papír a világon az
nvidia
részvényt megjósolja valamilyen számra
és megnézzük hogy akkor a a múltban
ténylegesen a 301 napon
a az a szám mennyire tért el tehát mi
volt a az eltérést ezt még általában
négyzetre szoktuk emelni egyrészt azért
mert nem nem mindegy hogy
hogy mennyire hibázik ha kicsit hibázik
az nem olyan nagy baj viszont hogyha
nagyot hibázik az nagyon nagy baj ugye
pénzről van szó
és és akkor meg meg nyilván az viszont
mindegy hogy le vagy felhibázik mi azt
szeretnénk hogy minél pontosabb legyen
úgyhogy ezt is eltünteti a négyzet és
akkor ezeket a az összes papírnál nem
nem csak egy papír lesz hanem az összes
amit ami benne van ugye a tanuló
adathalmazunkb kiszámoljuk ezt a hibát
és a négyzeteket kiátlagoljuk és ebből
ebből meg tudjuk azt mondani hogy a
jelenlegi tudás szintjén ez a ez a gépi
tanulási modellünk ez a neurális háló
mennyit hibázott
és és a a dolog szépsége hogy a a ugye
az emberek nem mindig tanulnak a
hibáikból viszont a a gépek azok mindig
tanulnak a hibáikból és és ennek a
szakkifejezése ez a back propagation of
errors tehát a amikor a hiba az
visszamegy a hálón és megpróbálja úgy
állítani ezeket a nagyon szimpla
neuronokat hogy hogy kevesebb legyen a
hiba és még kevesebb és még kevesebb és
akkor azt látjuk hogy hogy a
tanulásán folyamatosan hát úgy mondják
ezt hogy pokról pokra tehát hogy minden
így mindig amikor átnézi a teljes
adathalmazt akkor mindig azt látjuk hogy
csökken csökken csökken a hiba és és ezt
gyakorlatilag ismételhetnénk a
végtelenségig de nyilván nincs végtelen
erőforrásunk úgyhogy egy adott
pillanatban azt mondjuk hogy na most már
elégedettek vagyunk elég kicsi a hiba
ahhoz hogy ezt egy verziónak el tudjuk
könyvelni és akkor leállítjuk a tanulást
annál is inkább mert ezután a pont után
már már nagyon kis eredményt kapunk
nagyon picit javul ez a hiba viszont
óriási mennyiségű erőforrásba
kerül és ezt ezt nyilván mindig el kell
dönteni hogy mi az amit még itt
bevállalunk de hogy az elején mindig az
van hogy nagyon nagyon nagyon meredeken
esik a hiba és utána a végén beáll egy
ilyen egy ilyen platóba amikor már alig
csökken a hiba de mindig ez a
hibacsökkenés az
amitől amitől tanul a gép
és hogyha egy egy
komplexebb esetet nézünk akkor még
inkább nyilvánvaló egy egy csomó olyan
dolog ami a a köznyelvbe és a
médiában egy kicsit összezavarhatja az
embereket a a az egyik ilyen dolog az a
az az úgynevezett hallucináció jelensége
amit a média így
aposztrofált amikor ugye azt
tapasztaljuk hogy megkérdezzük a a c
gpt-t valamiről és akár a legújabb
négyó vagy omicron vagy
bármilyen változata is a a a az open a
gpt modelljének de ugyanez igaz a google
geminira vagy az untrophic 3.5 sonetre
vagy bármelyik nagy népszerű nyelvi
modellre azt tapasztaljuk hogy hogy nem
a valóságot adja vissza hanem hanem
kitalál valamit és ezen nagyon sokan úgy
meglepődtek főleg az elején ugye
hagyományosan az volt az emberek
elképzelése hogy a gép nem téved és ez
így így ilyen paradigmaszerűen így így
elterjedt a az emberek körébe ugye a
a ha ha más nem akkor a a bankoknál a
hitelelbírállásnál szokták azt hallani
külföldön is meg nálunk is az emberek
hogy hát a a gép azt mondta hogy és
akkor az úgy van nyilván ennek van van
egy
ilyen pszichológiai vonzata is hogy
azért szeretünk a gépekben megbízni
ezzel szemben meg azt láttuk hogy
kérdezzünk valamit mondjuk a chat
gpt-től a péld kedveér és például egy
könyvészetet kérünk és akkor egy
tökéletesnek kinéző könyvészetet
kigenerál linkekkel meg hivatkozásokkal
ami nem létezik igen vagy hogy mondjak
egy még konkrétabb példát ugye tegnap
voltak a parlamenti választások a chat
gpt a ezt posztol is a facebookra úgy
gondolta hogy tegnap a parlamenti
választások második fordulója van
romániában nyilvánvalóan ez ez nem igaz
de de
hogy
annyira nem volt nem volt tisztáb
nyilván a modell nincs annan tudja hogy
most hány fordulóba szervezik meg meg
meg rengeteg ilyen példa van és és ez
egyrészt felhívja a figyelmet arra hogy
mindig fontos elolvasni a a kimenetet
fontos minőség biztosítani a modellt
nem nem hisszük el csak úgy főleg akkor
hogyha egy tisztán nyelvi modellről van
szó mint a chatgpt és ugyanakkor pedig
ennek az oka ez ez nagyon egyszerű
hogyha valamire nem tudja a pontos
választ egy nagynyelvű modell akkor egy
olyan választ próbál generálni ami
legalábbis hihető mert ő ő mindig a
hibát próbálja minimalizálni mindig
próbálja elkerülni a hibát és a valami
az mindig kevesebb hiba mint a semmi
tehát hogyha semmit nem vál valamire az
az mindig maximális hiba lesz tehát az a
az az hogy ne válaszoljon semmit az az
software bug egy egy nagynyelmi
modellnél az összeomlik a modell de
érdekes hogy ez az embereknél is pont
így van tehát a tétlenség az nagyobb
hiba mint hogyha hibásan elkezdünk és
valamit valamit elkezdünk cselekedni
mert utólag aztán tudjuk korrigálni az
utunkat de hogyha el se indulunk akkor
valójában valójában ez a legnagyobb hiba
ez ez abszolút így van
viszont ugye a a a hagyományos
informatikai rendszereknél
hogyha a az ember gondol egy egy
keresőre a ott hogyha elnézést ha nem
talál meg valamit a kereső akár még egy
komplex mit tudom én egy ilyen elastic
search alapú kereső vagy vagy bármilyen
egy modern keresési megoldás akkor nem
fog kitalálni egy egy más dolgot
helyette hanem csak simán visszaadja azt
az informatikai rendszert hogy erre
nincs talállat
de a a a gépitanulásnál nem így van
illetve ennek van egy másik folyománya
is hogy még a a a
különböző hát úgymond numerikus
módszerek tehát ahol egy ilyen exakt
matematikával végig tudjuk vinni a
módszert a tehát az ilyen alapú
programok azok azok mindig pontos
eredményt fognak adni ami ami nagyon jó
is most gondoljuk el hogy a a vannak
könyvelési programok például azt nem
szeretnénk hogyha a
a ha az eredmény amit a könyvelési
program nekünk kiszámol az csak az
esetek
99%-ából lenne jó de 1%-ában tévedne na
most ezzel szemben a a mélyneurális
hálók kimenete az soha nem lesz 1.0
pontosságú tehát ez a jóslási pontosság
ez ez soha nem lesz
100%-os viszont
ugye nem is ez a cél hanem
a hanem pont pont az a az a célja
eredetileg a nagy nyelvi modelleknek
hogy hogy egy szép gördülékeny
szövegszerű jól megfogalmazott
mondatokból
álló gyakorlatilag szöveget adjanak
vissza
és és ebből a szempontból én úgy
gondolom hogy ezt a problémát sikerült
megoldani azt már az emberek elvárása
volt hogy akkor ez ez tárgyilag is
pontos legyen tehát hogyha most azt
mondja
a a gpt modell hogy
akkor mit tudom én valami így van akkor
az úgy is legyen na most a a másik dolog
ezzel hogy ezek mind előre tanított
modellek ugye ez a azt is rövidíti a gpt
hogy generative pretrained
transformer és a a a a p miatt ezek mind
mind mind előre tanított modellek ami
azt jelenti hogy abból hogy mi
beszélgetünk a modellel meg abból ami
most pillanatnyilag történik a világ
abból nem tanul a modellnek ez a
verziója a következő verzió az nyilván
tanulhat viszont az az majd a jövőben
fog kijönni ezért mondta azt a a chat
gpt amikor megjelent hogy neki csak 21
szeptemberéig van információja a
világról nyilván azóta sok frissítésen
átment de hogy az első megjelent
verziója ez ezt tta hogy mertogy ugye 21
nyagán jelent meg az a100-as videókártya
az nvidia ától ez a 80 gb véramos verzió
amit amit használtak a a tanításra és
akkor az történt hogy a a lezárták a
tanuló adatharmas szeptemberben és ami
azelőtt történt a világban azt tudtam
modell ami azután azt nem nyilván a ma
már vannak olyan megoldások amik tudnak
keresni a neten viszont az a az a netes
keresés az a az az nem a modellnek a a
tudása nem a
tanulóadathalmaz hanem az egy kisegítő
információforrás azt hiszem hogy a
perplexity a leg leghíresebb erről hogy
próbál forrásokat keresni és ezekből a
forrásokból próbálja kiegészíteni a a
tudásbázisát és így próbál legalábbis az
elérhető források alapján a
lehetőlepontosabb válaszokat adni és
ugyanúgy ezért van az hogy a perplexity
sokkal naprakészebb információkat tudott
például a a romániai parlamenti
választásokról akár aznap meg tudtad
kérdezni hogy jelenleg hány százaléknál
van a jelenlét meg mit mondanak a
közvéelmény kutatások meg bármi ilyesmi
attól nyilván a perplexity se tudta
megjósolni az eredményt
de de legalább viszonylag naprakész
információval rendelkezett itt egy
pillanat megállnék és összefoglalnám azt
a sok mindent amit eddig beszéltünk
azért hogy hogy utána aztán a tehát f
főként a hallgatók számára ne
kavarodjanak össze a dolgok a beszéltünk
a neurális hálókról és a gépi tanulásról
és arról is beszéltünk hogy részben a
hardw minősége miatt és a teljesítménye
miatt képesek lettünk
2021 és 2022 novemberében jelen meg ugye
a chat gpt mint mainstream a a bárki
által elérhető chat
applikáció gyakorlatilag képesek lettünk
arra hogy egy olyan
nyelvi modellt állítsunk elő amelyik
gyakorlatilag a turing tesen átmegy a
turing test az amikor amikor valaki egy
fallal egy fallal elzárva kommunikál egy
egy entitással és abban a pillanatban
mihelyt már nem tudja eldönteni hogy
emberrel vagy géppel kommunikál abban a
pillanatb azt a gépet azt a azt a
modellt úgy nevezzük hogy átment a ting
teszten én úgy hallottam hogy voltak még
próbálkozások amelyek úgymond sikeresnek
voltak titulálva előtte de gyakorlatilag
ez azért egy teljesen más dimenziót
hozott be az emberek
életébe a nagynyelvi modellek bár
mainstreamen 2022 novemberében jelentek
meg én azért már előtte is hallottam és
kíváncsi vagyok hogy te mennyivel előtte
tudtad már hogy hogy ez valami lesz ez
valami nagy dolog készülődik biztos
vagyok benne hogy már előtte láttad a a
a hog hogy hogy valami fog jönni csak
éppen nem lehet tudni mikor robban ki
igen azt azt lehetett sejteni hogy hogy
nyilván utólag mindenki nagyon okos de a
ugye a mindenki azt várta hogy hardver
szintjén jöjjön egy olyan áttörés amivel
pénzügyi ileg legalábbis elképzelhető
hogy nagyon nagy modelleket tanítsunk és
ugye maga a a tudományos része az jóval
hamarabb megvolt ugye a a természetes
nyelvek feldolgozásával már nagyon rég
kísérleteznek a a kutatók még az én
születésem előtt is kísérleteztek az már
több mint 40 éve volt de a a
ami ebből a szem pontból egy egy kiemelt
áttörés volt
az
2017-ben pontosan a google-nél egy
kutatócsoport kiadott egy
olyan cikket aminek az a címe hogy
attention is all you need tehát hogy a
figyelem az egyetlen dolog amire
szükséged van és ők azt mondták hogy egy
ilyen úgynevezett figyelem
mechanizmussal sokkal jobb eredményeket
tudunk elérni a természetes nyelv
feldolgozásában
mint mint az addigi megoldásokkal és
ugye az addigi
megoldásoknak az volt a nagy nagy
problémája hogy a a modellek nem nem
tudták hogy hogy miről is szól ez
a ez a szöveg amit te írtál neki és amit
meg kellett próbáljon értelmezni és erre
erre válaszolni ugyancsak úgy úgyhogy az
szóljon valamiről
és és
erre a talán a legjobb példa az hogy ha
egy angolul jobban működik mivel hogy
nem egy egy ragozó nyelv
hogyha azt mondjuk
a a a modellnek hogy magyarul úgy jönn
ki hogy ha a tenger
hatalmak legyőzték a szövetségeseket
vagy a szövetségesek legyőzték a
tengelyhatalmakat ez a az addigi nyelvi
modelleknek a két kijelentés az teljesen
egyedértékű volt nyilván nekünk
embereknek nem az de angolul axis
defeated the allies vagy allies defeated
the ais az az addigi modelleknél ahol
nem volt meg ez a figyelem mechanizmus
ez nagyon sok modell ezt ezt ugyanúgy
kezelte mivel hogy ugyanaz a három szó
van benne csak más sorrendbe más más
sorrendbe
és és itt ez a sorrend nagyon nem
mindegy de nyilván ez ez komplexebb
esetekben még még jobban
kijön ugye azt arra már sokkal hamarabb
rájöttek hogy hogy
lehet szavak közötti összefüggéseket
találni már jóval a transformer
architektúra előtt tudták azt a nagyon
klasszikus példát hogy a nagynyelvi
modell meg tudta mondani hogy ha azt
mondjuk hogy a a
egy ilyen hasonlításba hogy a a a férfi
és nő és utána hozzunk erre a modellre
egy egy olyan verziót amiben benne van a
király akkor azt a nyelvi modell mondta
hogy akkor a királynő lesz ide a
megfelelő szó tehát ilyen ilyen
szempontból ezek ezek működtek ami a ami
viszont nem működött ez a ez a figyelem
de de nagyon sok minden tehát a a
tokenizáció működött hogy a a
természetes nyelv szavait át tudjuk
alakítani számokká úgyhogy ilyen
darabokra vágjuk
szótöredékekre és a többi és a többi
tehát hogy hogy nagyon sok alapja már
megvolt viszont
ezzel azóta úgy hívjuk az attention is
all unit paperre alapuló modelleket hogy
a transformer architektúrájú modellek na
most ezek a ugye a a chat gptbe is a t
betű ez a transformert
jelenti ezekkel eljutottunk oda hogy
kvázi
élőbeszédszerű beszélgetést tudunk
folytatni egy nagy modellel és és én úgy
gondolom hogy
ezzel noha folyamatosan jelennek meg
cikkek arról
hogy hogy ez vagy az lesz a következő
nagy nagy áttörés a
nyelvfelismerésben viszont a az
átlagfelhasználó számára magából a
nyelvfelismerésből kihoztunk egy olyan
szintet amivel már azt mondjuk hogy ez
így rendben van és azzal hogy
a megjelent az úgynevezett retrieval
augmented generation ezek a rang
megoldások amivel a
valóságból általunk igaznak vett
információkat
be tudunk tenni
a a kimenetbe és akkor akkor a valóságot
fogja mondani és ez például jó arra
hogyha ha van egy cégnek egy
tudásbázisa mit tudom én van
egy egy ingatlan közvetítő iroda és és
szeretnénk egy olyan chatbotot csinálni
ami a jelenleg mondjuk
székelyudvarhelyen eladó
ingatlanokról visszaad információt ha
meg kérdezzük mit tudom én k kérünk egy
olyant hogy szeretnénk-e három szobás
lakást venni azt hol és mennyiért tudunk
találni udvarhelyen akkor el tudja
mondani ebbe az utcába ennyiért és a
többi na ahogy ezt meg tudja mondani
nyilván ezt a chgpt abszolút nincs hnan
tudja viszont hogyha van egy úgynevezett
tudásgráfunk ami amiben benne vannak
ezek az információk ami valószínűleg
hogy egy ingatlan közvetítőnél ezek az
információk megvannak valamilyen
relcionális vagy nem relacionális
adatbázisba már most onnan egy lépés az
hogy hogy átkerüljenek egy vektor
adatbázisba és gyakorlatilag ettől
tovább mi úgy mint egy ingatlan
ügynökkel tudunk csevegni ezzel a
modellel az még egy kicsit messzébb van
hogy el is vigyen az illető ingatlambas
ot bejárja velünk de de nem annyira
messze ugye látjuk a különböző
humanomanoid robotokat a amiket most
például a kínaiak nagyon
népszerűsítenek de már már
magyarországon is van olyan kávézó ahol
ilyen hát nem annyira humanoid de de
robotocskák viszik ki tárcán az italokat
és lehet náluk rendelni és satöbbi és és
igazából az hogy természetes nyelven
rendeljünk az ahhoz már robot se kell
ugye a az egyesült államokban is meg
arabországokban is egyre népszerűbbek
ezek a az ilyen drá ilyen áthajtós
gyorsét termek ahol van egy ilyen
mikrofon és a mikrofonba elmondod hogy
mit szeretnél enni
és és ezt ha csak nincsen nagyon erős
angol akcentusod akkor ezt megérti
felveszi a rendelésedet és utána mikor
tovább értél akkor megkapod a az
elkészült kaját úgyhogy nyilván nálunk
annyira nem népszerűek a driveet
gyorsértelmek de de itt itt például egy
abszolút előny tud ez lenni ha tetszik
ez az epizód akkor kérlek ne felejtsetek
el feliratkozni a csatornánkra osszátok
meg valamint hagyjatok egy kommentet
ezzel nagyban segítitek a munkánkat
2022 szeptemberét bocsánat novemberétől
kezdve bizonyos szempontból a világ
felbojdult és megjelent a chat gpt
3.5-ös modell ami
gyakorlatilag ez volt az első mainstream
modell amit bárki el tudott érni és már
tudta használni és utána pedig
folyamatosan jelennek meg az újabb és
újabb hírek például most az egyik az
hogy már nem csak szöveget hanem képet
is tud generálni ez a dolly most már
kettes modell és azt hiszem hogy már
hármas is
van és utána pedig megjelent a a
videogenerálási lehetőség és persze
mindenféle híresztelések hogy ilyen
deepfakeeket lehet készíteni most már
hangokat lehet utánozni
és tehát a az átlagember csak kapkodja a
fejét hogy szintre szinte hónapról
hónapra sőt már hétről hétre olyan hírek
érik el a a az átlagfelhasználót hogy
hogy egyrészt egy félelem is van benne
hogy mi lesz a jövő és hogy neki hol a
helye és hogy hogyan kell erre
felkészülni kezdetben mit szólnál hogyha
végigmennénk azokon a nagyobb
eseményeken ami az elmúlt két évben
történt azért hogy hogy most kábé hogy
tudja a a a hétköznapi ember is most még
egys egyszer mondom a hétköznapi ember a
tanár és a a a egy egy egy felszolgáló
egy étteremben aki
aki ha szeretned szeretnéd tudni hogy
hogy h hol áll most éppen a mesterséges
intelligencia hol állnak a fejlesztések
melyek a legnagyobb hírek most mi lenne
a top öt legnagyobb hír amit úgy
megemlítenél abba vagy top 10 akár így
fejből és és utána pedig rátérhetünk
arra hogy milyen is lesz a jövő mire
kell
felkészüljünk ez ez egy nagyon jó kérdés
igen tehát a
hogyha hogyha egy
picit visszább megyünk akkor én úgy
gondolom hogy az első nagy nagy
mérföldkő az az pont 10 évvel ezelőtt
volt amikor megjelentek a a genek a
generative adversarial networkok ami
gyakorlatilag azt jelenti hogy van két
neurális háló és a
egymással szemben van a hibájuk
a az egyik generálja a válaszokat és a
másik egy úgynevezett diszkriminátor
amelyik megpróbálja eldönteni hogy
melyik a melyik a jó válasz és melyik a
nem melyik az ami mondjuk a valóságból
származik és melyik az ami a kitaláció
és itt itt gondoljunk arra
hogy ez például hogyha a képeknél talán
a leg legegyértelműbb ugye
elképzelhetjük a generátort mint egy
festő ami festi a képeket millió számra
és a disk inátor pedig az egy ilyen
műkritikus ami nem tudja azt hogy a
melyik képet festette az ai és melyik
képet festette egy ismert nagy művész
véletlenszerűen kap mind a kettőből és
neki az a feladata hogy el kell
határozza hogy ezt most ai festette ezt
most nem és akkor így egyrész lesz egy
olyan modellünk ami ami sokkal jobban
tud képeket alkotni ja meg a generátor
is ebből tanul hogy próbál kijátszani a
diszkriminátort próbál valósághűnek
tűnni és ugyanakkor lesz egy olyan
modellünk ami azt meg tudja mondani hogy
az adott
modell festette azt a képet vagy ez
pedig egy valódi kép na most itt nagyon
fontos az hogy
a csak az adott modell ugye a nagyon
gyakran feltevődik a te általad is
említett depfékek meg minden egyéb tél
nagyon nagyon gyakran feltelődik az a
kérdés hogy meg tudjuk-e mondani azt azt
valamiről és hosszú távon meg fogjuk
tudni
mondani hogy hogy azt ember vagy gép
készítette hogy az deep fake vagy nem és
jelen pillanatban úgy néz ki hogy ezt
csak akkor tudjuk
megmondani egész biztosan hogyha
ismerjük azt a modellt ami generálja
mert azzal be lehet tanítani egy olyan
másik modellt ami megmondja hogy ezt
most a a tengerály generálta vagy ezt
most a a m journey generálta vagy ezt
most a dali generálta mert mert hogy
ezek ismert modellek viszont hogyha
valaki betanít egy olyan modellt amire a
mi mondjuk úgy hogy ai detektorunkat nem
nem készítettük fel arró az ai detektor
nem fogja tudni megmondani ha az jól be
van tanítva hogy az az egy
létező modell vagy pedig egy
egy ember alkotást mondjuk mer aki
megcsinálta photoshopba vagy vagy simán
lefényképezte és
a ezen kívül a a másik dolog hogy ugye
2017-et szokták a a a deep
fakeek nek a az ai videóknak a hát az
első mérföld
kövének tekinteni
egyrészt
azért mert ekkor jelentek meg hát mai
mai
szemmel
még még nagyon primitív deepfékek
viszont a 2017-ben a világ abszolút nem
volt erre felkészülve hogy ai generáljon
bármit is éppen ezért ekkor jött először
a köztudatba de nyilván az folyamatosan
fejlődik és a
ugye a 22-ben amint min azt már
említetted akkor kijött a 3.5 turbó
és
érdekes módon
23-ban kijött a hogy nyelvi modelleknél
maradjunk kijött egy egész
só hát én úy úgy mondanám hogy
ugrásszerű javulás ezen a téren egyrészt
kijött a gpt 4
modell is másrészt pedig kijöttek a a
sokkal jobb képgenerálók ugye a a a
tengriáis nyílv betába 23-ba került hogy
hazabeszéljek
és és ugyanakkor pedig ami ami szintén
szerintem nagyon fontos hogy hogy
23-ba legalábbis amiről én tudok volt az
első olyan eset amikor a deepfakeek
eldöntötték egy ország sorsát most ez
egy kicsit drámaian
hangzik de de a de a helyzet is az volt
és a a leg legdurvább ebben az egészben
az hogy nem is kellett
ehhez valójában ét használni az történt
hogy gabonban volt egy alibongo nevű
elnök
és ez egy
ht ilyen életfolytig elnök volt már az
apja is elnök volt és a
többi
és ami ami
történt hogy a bizonyos alib bongó
súlyosan megbetegedett ezért külföldön
kezelték na most az ellenzéke ott és és
a külföldiz elés alatt videóüzenetekbe
jelentkezett be a
népéhez na most a az ellenzéke azt
kezdte terjeszteni hogy alibongo meg van
halva és ezek csak deep fake videók
ezeket aial generálta háttérhatalom így
akarják a a gaboni népet félrevezetni
megvezetni külföldről
irányítani bármi ilyesmi és és képzeld
el azt a helyzetet amikor neked mint
politikus az ellen kell kampányol hogy
valaki azt mondja hogy te halott vagy és
és szó szerint ez történt
és és végül mindez
odavezetett
hogy hogy ugye a a az emberek az utcára
vonultak nem túl békés hangulatban
nyilvánvalóan a a a a a a a
rendszerváltások azok láthattuk hogy
romániában se túl békés dolgok de de
hogy
gabonban hát ugye afrikai ország révén
azért e ennek mindig van egy ilyen egy
ilyen felfokozott hangulata de a a vége
az lesz
hogy hogy akkor egy egy sikeres puccsot
hajtottak végre alibongo ellen
a és és én én én úgy gondolom hogy
ez ez azokat is érdekelheti akik
lehet hogy hogy sa életükben nem
hallottak
gabonról
viszont viszont abból a szempontból
nagyon nagyon fontos üzenete van hogy az
ai generált tartalmaknak és a deep
fakeeknek
óriási hatása van a társadalomra és nem
csak az egyesült államokban ugye most a
az elnökválasztási kampány kapcsán
lehetett hallani mindenféle híreket az
egyesült államokban szerencsére
romániában
én úgy gondolom hogy a politikai pártok
is még egy picit le vannak maradva és
majd a következő
elnökválasztási mondjuk nem tudom neked
mi volt a véleményed de én így figyelve
az amerikai választásokat én azt hittem
hogy sokkal több ai által történő
interferálást fogok majd észrevenni de
talán most még nem volt annyi mindenki
azt jósolta az ai-ok háborúja lesz ez a
a a ez a választás valójában itt fog itt
fog eldőlni az hogy most mennyire
interferál majd be a választásokba a a a
a mesterséges intelligencia neked mi
volt a tapasztalatod az amerikai
választásokkal kapcsolatban hogy hogy
voltak nagyobb botrányok ezzel
kapcsolatban
én úgy gondolom hogy hogy ezt ezt
szerencsésen
átvészeltük mert mert nem ettől volt
hangos és én úgy gondolom hogy ez
mindenként jó a a gépitan ás jövőjének
nem nem szeretné azt senki hogy a gépi
tanulás összekapcsolódjon a botrányokkal
a csalásokkal a deepféekkel satöbbi
nyilván a az azt gondolom hogy nagyon
sok emberhez eljutott egy egy
mesterséges intelligenciával generált
kép
ahol trumpot letartóztatják és látszik
hogy a a rendőrök bilincselik meg
satöbbi nyilván ez ez nem történt meg a
a a valóságba ugyanúgy ahogy a a a a
pápáról készült kép balenciagá de hogy
hogy ez a kép az a mshot kép ez ez egy
generált kép nem egy eredeti amikor
letartóztatták
trumpot én én úgy tudom hogy
ez ez egy generált kép és és ez egy elég
híes elég híres esete a a a a az ai
general
képeknek viszont van egy
a az érdekes az hogy a a a
maxsat ami a a georgia sheriff
hivatalától került ki az az az viszont
valódi lehet annál is inkább
mert mert ezt ezt trump maga is
posztolta a twitteren vagyis akkor már x
volt igen erre gondoltam igen sóval hogy
hogy soha nem adom fel de de volt
hamarabb egy egy olyan ahol ahol nem nem
egy ilyen makshot volt itt itt ugye
nemr most már nagyon nehéz eldönteni de
van egy van egy olyan van egy olyan kép
ahol
a és erről van egy bbc-s cikk is
ahol egy ai-jal generált deepfake van
ahol három
rendőr bilincs próbálja vinni trumpot
ezt be is teszem ide a chatbe de a a
bbcs cikket az az viszont aial generált
egész biztosan és és t ez egy nagyon
érdekes dolog hogy a ez ugye hamagabb is
volt és aztán vannak vannak itt még
durvább képek is milyen nagyobb hírek
vannak még most ami ami 2024
decemberében
releváns lehet
és érdemes megemlíteni a hallgatók
számára milyen nagyobb
fejlesztések hát én én úgy gondolom hogy
a a amit nagyon sok ember várt az a az
hogy ai-al
lehessen hollywoodi minőségben filmeket
videókat satöbbi generálni ugye ezt a a
az open ai sora néven nagy elan be is
harangozta viszont
se ők se mondjuk a a kínai csinka
egyetem nem nem nem engedte ki a
nyilvánosság számára ezeket a modelleket
és én úgy gondolom hogy ennek elsősorban
hardver oka van ugyanis a képgenerálés
is elég hardver igényes viszont sokkal
inkább hardverigényes a vide generálás
jelen pillanatban nem elég olcsó főleg
hogy az nvidiának kvázi monopol helyzete
van és és nem is tudja szállítani és és
mondjuk egy dgx szerver 400000 dollár
nem elég olcsó a hardver ahhoz
hogy hogy videókat generáljunk szabadon
az interneten jó
minőségbe megkötések nélkül nyilván
olyan megoldások vannak amik képeket
megmozgatnak satöbbi de ezek én úgy
gondolom hogy még nagyon a gyerekcipőben
vannak és itt megint egy hardveres
ugrásra vár mert a a technika az
létezik használható a paperek megvannak
viszont ezt a következő nagy hardveres
ugrás akár lesznek cél hardverek
inferenciára akár az nvidiának az árai
lenne mennek bármi is történjen hard ezt
fogja elhozni hogy akkor videókat tudunk
generálni és a másik dolog ami ami
szintén nagyon új
az az hogy megjelent az első olyan
próbálkozás ahol
számítógépes játékot próbál képkockáról
képkockára generálni a az ai tehát itt
egy egy ilyen
minecraft
szerű játékról van szó egy bizonyos
oázis ai nevű projekt ami gyakorlatilag
azt csinálja hogy hogyha megnyomod a
jobbra gombot akkor kigenerálja azt a
képet amit a modell szerint te a
minecraftban látnál hogyha megnyomnád a
jobbra gombot ez ez én úgy gondolom hogy
mindenként inkább technikai demó én nem
ebbe látom a videó játékoknak az ai
generálta jövőjét én sokkal inkább abban
hiszek hogy hogy nem képkockánként
fogunk inferenciát kérni
nemképkockánként fogunk ai-al generálni
videjátékot hanem magát a videjátékot
fogjuk legenerálni ai-jal egybe és ez
így sokkal
költséghatékonyabb és utána lesznek
ai-al generált játékok és amúgy ez nekem
most az egyik kedvenc kutatási
területen hogy hogy hogy
lehet ai-al
játékokat generálni hogy lehet ezt ezt
úgy megoldani hogy akkor egy angal
enginebe futó mindennel
rendelkező játék jöjjön létre amit utána
lehet szerkeszteni mert nyilván nem
tökéletes soha az ai-nak a kimenete és
végül akkor egy akár steamen futó játék
legyen ez az egyik ami nagyon érdekes a
másik szerintem a a ami kimondottan
érdekes az erdélyi magyarság számára meg
meg főleg az egy olyan probléma amit
most már nem az egyesült államokba hanem
indiába oldottak meg nagy nagyon szépen
ugye indiának az a nagy problémája hogy
vagy nem probléma hanem ez a ez a
helyzet kihívása kihívása igen hogy 22
plus hivatalos nyelv van indiában
és és ugye az ugye azt azt láthatjuk
hogy romániában egy közalkalmazotttól
már az is nehezen várható el hogy két
nyelvet beszéljen nem hogy
22-t éppen ezért ez egy ez egy óriási
kihív á és ezt ai-al egy ai for barat
nevű projekt keretében úgy oldották meg
hogy az önkormányzati űrlap
kitöltéseket mindenki anyanyelvén
tudja megoldani és ráadásul nem egy
ilyen jogi szöveges ai-os
formában
hanem úgy hogy azt mondja hogy mit tudom
én mi a neved és akkor az illető
megmondja a nevét utána megkérdezi hogy
hol hol laksz akkor megmondja a lakcímét
hogyha nem egy teljes vagy nem egy jó
lakcímet ad akkor akkor segít kijavítani
a hibát és a többi tehát úgy érezheti az
illető polgár minthogyha egy hivatali
ügyintéző az anya nyelvén beszélne vele
ráadásul ennek van egy másik
óriási előnye hogy ugye nagyon nagyon
sokan sajnos funkcionálisan alfabéták
nem csak indiában állunk is is és és
ugye ezeknek az embereknek pedig megint
csak óriási segítség hogy nem egy ilyen
jogi bükfanyelven megfogalmazott
űrlapot kell kitölteni hanem elbeszélget
egy ilyen
chatbottal azért ugye a ha facebook
messengeren tud valaki beszélgetni akkor
valószínűleg a chatbottal is fog tudni
beszélgetni és akkor így így eljutunk
oda hogy
akkor azon a nyelv ben kigenerálódik a
kitöltött űrlap amin az adott hivatalnak
az kell de a az az illető az anyanyelvén
kommunikálhatott a a a chatbottal és én
úgy gondolom hogy ez óriási segítség
lenne nekünk erdélyi magyaroknak
is és és nem csak az egész unió
területén ez egy ez egy hihetetlenül
fontos dolog lenne
részben ugye a a a nemzeti kisebbségek
számára
de de akkor is hogyha valakinek az
anyanyelve az államnyelve akkor is
segíthet ugye senki nem szeret űlapokat
kitölteni én úgy gondolom vagy szinte
senki de de gondoljunk arra hogy vannak
fogyatékkal élők
például vakok és gyengén látók akiknek
ez nagyon sokat segít vagy az előbb
említett funkcionális analfabetizmus és
én úgy gondolom hogy az ilyen és ehhez
hasonló
megoldások amik az emberek életét jobbá
veszik
ezek lesznek a következő egy két három
öt év legfontosabb mérföldkövei a amik a
a gépi tanulást
illetik ezek ezek nagyon érdekes új
lehetőségek amiket említettél és nagyon
izgalmasak egy kicsit beszélgetnék arról
hogy az a személy aki eddig hallott róla
és úy kicsit óckodott hogy neki fogjon
interakcióba lépni egy gpt-vel vagy akár
clouddal vagy vagy mostanában grockot
kezdtem tesztelni
hogy mit tanácsolsz hogy hogy fogjon
neki az átlagember mit mit érdemes
megtanulni mi az amit érdemes gyakorolni
mire tudná használni az átlagember a a
hétköznapjaiban ezt a nagynyelvi modellt
vagy ezeket a nagynyelvi modelleket én
én úgy gondolom hogy egy egy nagynyelvi
modellt leginkább arra érdemes használni
hogy hogy szebben és jobban
megfogalmazzon szövegek ugye a nagyon
sok ember
nem nem szeret hosszú szövegeket
fogalmazni főleg nem olyan nyelven ami
nem az anyanyelve most mindegy hogy
angolra vagy románra vagy szerbre
gondolunk ez ez abszolút benne van és
akkor hogyha leírjuk vonalkákba hogy mit
szeretnénk de legyen benne az hogy
pontosan mi az amit el szeretnénk
mondani akkor arra szerintem már most
tökélet esek a nagynyelvi modellek hogy
hogy ezt szép
szavatos mondatokban jó helyes írással
megfogalmazzák adott
terjedelembe és és ehhez
nagyon minimális extra dolgot
kell elsajátítani igazából el kell menni
a weboldalra és ki kell ezt próbálni van
van egy olyan iránymutatás
egy ilyen hát úgy hívják ezeket hogy
frameworkok ahogy érdemes promtolni
ezeket a nyelvi
modelleket és ebből ebből van több is de
alapvetően nem nem muszáj azzal kezdeni
hogy most megtanulunk egy ilyen coyle
vagy más promtolási frameworkot hanem
sokkal egyszerűbb azzal kezdeni hogy
kipróbáljuk hogy a mi szavad szavas
leírásunkra mit ad vissza a nyelvi
modell nyilván szem előtt tartva azt
hogy a a nyelvi modell az egész nem jó
matekből tehát
hogyha vannak ez irányba is haladást ez
az o1 preview ami megjelent igen a ass
sonet 3.5 is egész jó tud lenni az
antrophictól de de alapvetően nem erre
voltak kitalálva a nagynyelvi modellek
hogy most komplexebb matematikai
problémákat vagy akár szimplább
matematikai problémákat megoldjanak ugye
nagyon soká igazzal
úgymond tesztelgették a modelleket hogy
egy egy szóba számolja meg hogy melyik
betűből hány van például és bizonyos
esetekben ezt
is elgond nehezére esett ezeket a
szótagszerű tokenek miatt gondolom így
van így van egyrészt azért mert mert
hogy nem nem
betűnként vannak a tokenek magyar
nyelven
amúgy sok esetben betűnként vannak de
angolul inkább ilyen ilyen szótakszerűen
vagy odot esetben egy egész szó is lehet
egy toket igen tehát hogyha most a
hallgató kedvéért praktikusan amit amit
megfogalmaztál ezt ezt úgy lehet hogy
hogy például a chat gpt-ben írunk egy
olyan szöveget hogy szeretnék egy emailt
írni ennek a személynek vonalkákban az
alábbi szövegben felsorolom hogy milyen
főbb gondolatok legyenek benne
felsoroljuk a gondolatokat és megkérjük
hogy generálj ki nekünk egy olyan
változatot erre az emailre amelyik
illedelmes és tömör és akkor kigenerál
nekünk egy első változatot amit akár
finomíthatunk és használhatjuk ezt akkor
helyes írás ellenőrzésre is tehát hogyha
már konkrétan van egy emailünk és azt
szeretnénk hogy ez az email egy picit
formálisabb legyen ne vagy vagy akár
angolul legyen formálisabb vagy
szeretnénk lefordítani angolra tehát
ezek már egyből ilyen alacsonyan függő
gyümölcsök amiket le
lehet szedni a fáról én még amire
személyesen használom nagyon sokat az
maga a gondol ás tehát a a az ember az
egy egy nagyon szociális lény és és a
gondolkodási folyamata nagyon verbális
tehát a legtöbb ember beszélve
gondolkodik miközben kimond egy
gondolatot ő közben is számára tisztul
és a másik személy ahogy reflektál a
gondolatunkra az is tisztítja a saját
magunk számára ezt a gondolatot úgyhogy
én azt láttam hogy sok esetben nem nem
vagyok olyan helyzetben hogy valami
komplex témáról vagy specifikus témáról
valakivel beszélhessek úgyhogy ilyenkor
rengeteget használom a a chat gpt-t és
elmondom a gondolataimat és a megkérem
hogy most ne szólj közbe most csak
okéval válaszolj minden egyes gondolatra
és akkor 10 percen keresztül magyarázok
neki amúgy a a a hangfelismerő
funkcióját nagyon ajánlom mindenkinek
nagyon jó még a magyar nyelven is nagyon
jó hangfelismerű funkciója van vagy ez a
a text to speech bocsos speech to text
vagyis hogy a szöveget a az a beszélt
szöveget írott szöveggé alakítja át ezek
hihetetlenül hatékonnyá teszik a az én
munkámat is vagyis hog rengeteg dolgot
diktálok le neki miközben sétálgatok a
parkba és a végén aztán azt kérem hogy
foglald össze azt amit mondtam és ez már
ez a desztillációs folyamat rengeteget
segít abban hogy megértsem hogy
valójában mit is mondtam mert ha ha a
kreatív elmémet szabadjára engedem akkor
nem egy annyira strukturált dolog az
amit mondok hanem egy picit úgy
össze-evissza van és akkor utána azzal
az a a a tudás kontextussal amit már a a
a felépítettem a a beszélgetés során egy
csomó mindent lehet kezdeni ez már egy
egy mondjam úgy egy haladóbb
felhasználása a chat
gpt-nek tehát ezt tudom ajánlanin a
hétköznapi embereknek van-e még valami
ami úgy így a fejedben nap min naap
esetleg amit használsz így
technikaként én én egy picit
strukturáltabban szoktam tehát amikor a
ugye nekem ez ez nagyon sokat segített
hogy van egy
ugye ahogy a program zásb is fontosak a
struktúrák hogy amikor a a a nagynyelvi
modellekkel is mindegy hogy melyikkel
vagy bármilyen gépitanolási
modell de most konkretizáljuk akkor
nagynyelvi modellre hogyha már ezt
hoztad fel most mindegy hogy melyik én
általában az ztrophic 3.5 sonettet
sokkal gyakrabban használom mint a a
nyós vagy yós
gpt
viszont mindenként ami amivel mindig
szoktam kezdeni az eg tehát hogy hogy
hogy mi az
a az a környezet például
hogyha tegyük fel valaki ezt ahogy
nagyon sokan használják marketing
szövegírásra akkor akkor kontextus az az
lenne hogy szeretném reklámozni a cégem
új termékét ez a cégemnek a neve ez az
új terméknek a neve és ezt csinálja ez
az új termék tehát hogy hogy meglegyen a
kontextus és utána minden további dolgot
ebbe a kontextusba tárgyalok és akkor
nem kell sokat ismételjem magam illetve
a nagynyelvi modell is sokkal
pontosabban tudja azt hogy itt mire kell
fókuszálni a másik pedig hogy mindig
kell egy egy cél például ebbe az esetben
azt mondom hogy akkor szeretnék-
facebook posztot és ugye az a célom hogy
minél több ember mit tudom én kattintson
a a linkre a facebook potról hogy
eljussön az én új
termékemhez utána pedig
amit amit
szintén segíthet főleg ilyen
marketingben hogy hogy egy pár szóval
vagy egy max mondattal leírom hogy
milyen stílusba szeretném tehát
hogy
kezdve azzal hogy most tegezem vagy
magázom a klienseimet hogy most nagyon
meggyőző mit tudom én akarok lenni és ez
ez a stílus és tónus ugy egyben van
tehát hogy hogy mit tudom én a akár azt
is mondhatom hogy olyan stílusba mint
ahogy valami mit tudom én ahogy a
coca-cola szokott kommunikálni hogyha az
nekem tetszik vagy lehet hogy olyan
stílusban szeretném mint ahogy az nvidia
vagy az ibm szokott kommunikálni úhogy
valamilyen valamilyen stílust igyekszek
megragadni ami talál ehhez vagy a másik
oldalról de ez akár lehet és is meg
szoktam fogalmazni azt hogy ki a
célcsoport ami mit tudom én ha olyan
termékeim vannak akkor a azt mondom hogy
az én csoportom olyan facebook
felhasználók akik az idősebb
generációból vannak
és vagy mit tudom én lehet hogy a fiatal
hölgyeket céloztam meg mondjuk mit tudom
én egy hajápolási termékkel vagy bármi
ilyesmi a a
végén pedig akkor ebből egy egy jól
összefoglalt rövid választ fogok kapni
ami pont megoldja ezt a problémát és
ugye nem felejtettem ki semmit ezzel
hogy hogy ezt ezt úgy hívják ezt amúgy
hogy a costar framework a ami úgy néz ki
hogy
kontextus cél mint objective s mint
stílus t mint tónus audience mint
hallgatóság és r mint response tehát
ezzel a callstar frameworkkal nem kell
az egészet kitölteni de hogyha a
kontextus megvan az már egy nagyon jó
kiindulási alap és így akkor tudom
garantálni azt hogy ha ezt megtartom és
a következő posztot és a rákövetkező
és így generálom akkor nagyon
minimálisat kell módosítsak nem kell
újra írjam ezt az egészet hanem azt
mondom hogy jó akkor generálj még egy
másik posztot és és ezért ezért jók a
modern nagy nyelvi modellek hogy hogy
megtartják a beszélgetésnek a a a
történetéalát bár a kontextus azt én
adom meg de hogy igen ezt például a
perplexity ezt tradek néven nevezi hogy
ilyen ilyen tredekbe tö és akkor vissza
fok menni légi tradbe és akkor azt
mondom h jó hát ebből a reklámból kérek
még egyet hogy rendben van
akkor akkor most erre kérnék egy
linkedines reklámot ami mondjuk ugyanez
csak mit tudom én a professzionális
közönségnek szól most már én mondtam egy
példát igen hogyha most a a hallgatók
azt mondják hogy ez már túl komplex
nekem így az jutott eszembe hogy
pontosan erre is jó a nagynyelvi modell
én például most nekifogtam cloud
technológiákat tanulni nem rég most a
lehet hogy az átlag hallgató nem tudja
mi az hogy cloud technológia de pontosan
erről van szó hogy ami ahogy elkezdtem a
az a a nyelvi modellel interakcióba
lépni leírtam hogy ki vagyok egy
kontextust adtam neki hogy mi mi is a
célom pontosan ahogy mondtad és
részleteztem hogy mi a a milyen
lépéseket szeretnék hogy milyen
technológiát szeretnék megtanulni és
segítsen nekem egy olyan tananyagot
létrehozni amivel ilyen mikrotanulásokba
tehát hogyha két-három percet van időm
tanulni egy egy adott életszakas
élethelyzetbe tegyük fel hogy most kell
várjak a fiamra az óvodából két-három
percet és szeretném valami produktívval
eltölteni akkor megtanítottam vagyis
megkértem hogy generáljon nekem egy
olyan tananyagot ahol ha azt mondom hogy
jöhet a következő rész akkor egy két
perc alatt
elolvasható rövid részt fog nekem adni
és strukturáltan végigvezet engem a
cloud technológiákon úgyhogy egy
nagyon-nagyon rövid
bevezetőt olvasok el valójában és hogyha
valamelyik része érdekel akkor azt
mondom hogy akkor szeretnék mélyebbre
menni jobban megérteni hogy akkor ez a
tárolási módszer például hogyan működik
és ez a szép benne hogy egyszerre tudunk
horizontálisan egy egy felületet egy egy
adott tudásanyagot átlátni és
mélységeibe hogyha szükségesnek látjuk m
mélyíteni tudjuk és ugyanúz érvényes
magára a promtolási technikákra ahogy
mondtuk tehát maga az hogy hogyan lépünk
interakcióba a chat gpt-vel hogy a a az
átlagfelhasznál
aki nem tudja ezt meg tudja kérni a chat
gpt-t hogy taníts meg engem hogy hogyan
használjalak téged készíts egy
tananyagot hogy hogyan tanuljak meg jól
veled interakcióba lépni és segíts nekem
kitalálni azt hogy hol tudom használni
az én életemben az adott kontextusomba
tegyük fel én egy könyvelő vagyok
romániában erdélyi magyar környezetben
segíts nekem megtalálni azt azokat a
módszereket hogy a a hatékonyságom
növekedjen a következő időszakban
azáltal hogy téged használak és erről
készíts egy tananyagot nekem amit két
per
rövid tartalmakban el tudok olvasni
úgyhogy ez például az egyik javaslatom a
a hallgatók számára engem nagyon érdekel
hogy tehát azt látom hogy itt a hatalmas
cégek mint a microsoft vagy a google
vagy most már az xai és az
antropic ezek rúgnak labdába akik saját
nyelvi modelleket tudnak gondolom az
nvidia is egy saját modellt a háttérben
elkezdett már trainelni gyanítom hogy
hogy azok akik megengedhetik de itt most
már milliárd dollárokról van szó és a
hétköznapi kis cégek nem tudom hogy
mennyire rúghhatnak itt labdába ez lenne
az első kérdésem hogy ebből a ebből a
szempontból ez nem így van mert az
európai unióban ezért vannak a
szuperszámítógépek amiket akár de
minimis támogatás formájában igénybe
lehet venni mint magyarországon a
kifinek a commandor szuperszámítógépe és
az ugyanazokból az a100-as
videokártyákból áll mint amit az open ai
használt a a gpt 3.5 turbó tanítására
és és il ilyen szempontból szerintem ez
ez ez kimondottan a nagy amerikai
nagyon gazdag multiknak a propaganda
tevékenysége hogy azt mondják hogy hogy
itt más nem lú labdába csak aki a
silicon worldben van és mindenki másnak
az az
egyetlen opciója hogy api hívásokból
kvázi használja az ő modelljeiket de
senki nehogy véletlenül tanítson modellt
mert az az túl drága nem lesz hardver
nem lesz semmi ez ez abszolút nem igaz
de sajnos ez annyira jól működik hogy
nagyon sok startup ezt elhiszi nagyon
sok befektető elhiszi
és és emiatt óriási versenyhátrányban
van az egész európa holott vannak a nagy
szuperszámítógépek sőt európában van
gépi tanulás szempontjából a legnagyobb
szuperszámítógép a marinostrum 5 a ami
ami világszinten is a top egy
gépianulásra való szuperszámítógép
úgyhogy én ebzel abszolút nem tudok
egyetérteni és ez egy nagyon káros
valami pontosan a startup ökoszisztémára
mert amúgy nagyon sokan ezt vallják hogy
ez akkor milliárd dollárok tanítani egy
modellt ez abszolút nincs így azok a
számok amiket amiket kiszámol mondjuk
egy open ai azok rettentően fel vannak
duzzastztva és benne van az hogy a a
gépi tanulás kutatóik több 100000
dollárt keresnek évente mint fizetés és
egy kutató és nagyon sok van és ugye a
google-nél is a a deep mine csapatba
több mint 1000 ember van mind óriási
fizetésekkel és hogyha ezeket az óriási
fizetéseket hozzáadjuk a
a a ahhoz hogy hogy mennyibe kerülnek
bizonyos operacionális költségek az
egyesült államokba és hozzáadjuk az
nvidiának a hardver költségeit akkor
tényleg milliárdos számok jönnek ki
viszont ezt sokkal okosabban meg lehet
csinálni az európai unióba és támogatja
is az európai unió az ilyen kutatásokat
és fejlesztéseket és a tagállamok is
például magyarország ezt nagyon
támogatja csak csak sajnos a én úgy kell
mondjam hogy ez ez propaganda mert ez
végül is az úgy állítja be hogy ez kvázi
európában lehetetlen vagy amerikán kívül
lehetetlen és a propagandának ilyen
szempont ó a második üzenete az hogy ha
meg is van a hardvered az információ
amiből tanítani tudod ezt a modellt ez
ez inkább azoknak áll a rendelkezésére
akik akik ilyen big tech company tehát
hozzáf például a google vagy vagy a
microsoft erre mit mondanál hogy az
információ az ami a a mondjuk a zseton a
játékban és ez viszont nem áll már
mindenkinek a rendelkezésére egy egy kis
kisebb startupnak ez se
igaz
mert ugye a a nagy modelleket nagy
publikus adathalmazokból tanítják és
ezek a nagy publikus adathalmazok
léteznek hogy mást ne mondjak ugye
mostanában nem publikálja az open ai
hogy miken
tanít de azt például tudjuk hogy a 3.5
turbót is tehát amivel a c gpt kijött és
a ugyanúgy a google geminit és minden
minden nagy nyelvi modellt az
úgynevezett file adathalmazzal
tanították és ez a pile adathalmaz ez
egy publikus mindenki számára elérhető
adathalmaz képgeneráló mesterséges
intelligenciát a lion adathalmazzal
tanított mindenki legalábbis az volt a
kezdeti nagy adathalmaz és ahhoz aztán
mindenki tesz hozzá képeket de a az
alapötlet és a nagyja az ott van és ezek
publikusan elérhető adathalmazok és a
big data korának pont az volt a lényege
hogy hogy megtanultunk nagy mennyiségű
adatot összegyűjteni és kezdeni valamit
és létrejöttek az adattavak léformation
satöbbi amiből aztán olyan struktúráv
tudjuk kinyerni ezeket az adatokat
amilyen pont kell tehát én én úgy
gondolom hogy az az abszolút nincs úgy
hogy hogy a a az amerikai startupoknál
vannak az
adatok sőt én úgy gondolom hogy ez
megint egy egy óriási előny lehet egy
európai startupnak
hogy törvénysz szerint ugye a gdpr óta
az európai polgárok adatait nem lehet
kivinni
európából és és éppen ezért hogyha ha
valaki olyan startupbaan gondolkozik ami
valamilyen szinten is európai polgárok
adataival bármit kezd még akkor is ha
nem is gépitanalásról van szó azt
mindenként csak európában lehet
megoldani legalábbis az adattárolást azt
mindenkén csak it lehet megoldani
úgyhogy én én nem nem nem gondolom azt
hogy hogy az adatok
oldalából különösebben nagy előnye lenne
és és az is biztos hogy önmagában az
hogy hatalmas
mennyiségű úgynevezett dirty d tát ilyen
nem tisztított adatot rádobunk egy
modellre az önmagában nem segít nagyok
lesznek a számok de nem lesz jobb a
modell pont ezért nagyon fontos az
adattisztti ás és adatfelfedezés része a
gépitanulásnak arra viszont európában
nagyon jó szakemberek vannak és
sokkalsokkal olcsóbbabb mint az egyesült
államokban úgyhogy én én ebből a
szempontból megint nem látom nekem nekem
az a az a benyomásom de mondom ez
személyes benyomás hogy az európai unió
elhitte azt hogy ő ő neekki itt nem
osztottak kártyát nincs esély ebbe a
versenybe és
és akkor le is mondott a mesterséges
intelligencia versenyfutásról
úgy unió szinten is de nagyon sok
startup szinten is és akkor nagyon sok
ai startup annyit csinál hogy akkor
meghív egy egy open ai vagy untrophic
vagy valamelyik más modellt api-ból és
akkor azt a modellt használja és arra
próbál valamit ráépíteni
merthogy nagyon jól működik ez hogy
hogyha ha valakivel el tudom hitetni azt
hogy ő esélytelen a versenybe akkor
kvázi megnyertem a versenyt még mielőtt
elkezdtünk volna
versenyezni ez nagyon érdekes amúgy
nagyon tetszik ez az az optimizmusod
úgyhogy utolsó kérdésként így kicsit az
ördög ügyvédjét játszom és én képviselem
a negatív a félelmetes
jövőt azt látom hogy ez az ai rengeteg
veszélyt rejteget magába például most
jelen pillanatban is az internet
forgalom 30%-a körülbelül pornográf
tartalmakat tartalmaz szóval és a a
mesterséges intelligencia gyakorlatilag
itt lesz elsőként használva úgy hogy
hogy még inkább valósághű modelleket még
inkább valósághű interaktív személyeket
fognak például
generálni és persze a a digitális
biztonság terén egy csomó csalás és egy
csomó
átverésnek a a a a helyét fogja majd
jelenteni így gyakorlatilag a a
mesterséges intelligencia teret enged
legalábbis ezeknek ezenkívül pedig
veszélyt látok a munkaerőpiacon hogy
rengeteg ember el fogja veszíteni a
munkáját emiatt ezekről tudom hogy
beszélgettünk zárásként milyen pozitív
jövőképet tudsz mondani a következő egy
évre és az öt évre
vonatkozóan igen én én úgy gondolom
hogy kezdetben minden technológiának
megvannak a veszélyei úgy úgy ennek is
és és a az emberek nagyon jók a abban
hogy hogy egy új technológiát mindenféle
rossz célra használjanak kezdve a
hadipartól a biológiai fegyverekig
bármire lehet használni a gépi tanulást
és vannak is példák
de ugyanúgy valószínűleg a
a belsőégési motorral sőt egész biztosan
ez volt ugye be tudom tenni autóba
buszba de ugyanakkor tankba is de
de ha még visszább megyünk valószínűleg
már az első
kőbaltánál megfordult az ősember fejében
hogy ezzel meg lehetne ölni valakit és
meg is tette úgyhogy ilyen szempontból
ebben nincs semmi újdonság ilyen az
emberi természet viszont azt láthatjuk a
technológia fejlődése során hogy mindig
egy kicsit jobb lesz az emberiségnek
mindig egy kicsit könnyebb lesz az
életünk és én úgy gondolom hogy egy
ilyen
ugrásszerű fejlő ődésnél mint a a
mesterséges intelligencia és itt nem a
nyelvi modellekre gondolok hanem hanem
mindenféle gépi tanulás alapú megoldásra
az az el tudja hozni az emberiség új
aranykorát ugye a az
iparosodással teljes társadalmi
átalakulások mentek végbe de végül is az
szerintem most már mindenki számára
egyértelmű hogy sokkal jobban élünk mi
most az iparosodás után mint az előtt
mondjuk a későközépkorban ahogy éltek a
a az elődeink és én úgy gondolom hogy ez
ezt fogja elhozni az új aranykort ez
fogja elhozni azt hogy sokkal kevesebbet
fogunk dolgozni ahogy például az
autógyártás elterjedése hozta el azt
hogy hogy nem hat nap 12 órát per nap
kellett dolgozzanak az emberek hanem
németország déli részén először ugye
badenwürberg állam területén a mondjuk a
mercedes gyárban bevezették a 8-9 órás
műszakot és a a heti öt napos
munkaprogramot ami aztán elterjedt
mindenhol pont azért mert az
autógyártásnak volt egy óriási
hozzáadott értéke és leghamarabb
szerintem a négynapos
munkahét elterjedését azt azt szerintem
mindenként a a a mesterséges
intelligencia
terjedésének köszönhetjük majd főleg az
irodai munká nál rengeteg munkaidőt
megspórol nekünk és ez egyre többet fog
ahogy haladunk előre az időben viszont a
a az emberi munka az sokkal inkább
döntéshozatali
innovációs és és olyan munka amit amit
szeretnek csinálni az emberek az ilyen
repetitív és nem szeretem munkákat
viszont kevésbé köszönöm nagyon szépen a
az idődet és n szeretném majd folytatni
más témákkal köszönöm még egyszer és
beszélünk majd még szia ha tetszett ez a
műsor akkor iratkozz fel kérlek a
csatornánkra ezzel tudsz támogatni
minket köszönjük a vckker
kávéközösségnek a jó kávéért az
ötvösudvarnak a helyért valamit a
bizalomtőkének a támogatásért nékületek
nem jöhetett volna ez létre